[Musique]
lundi ça fera un nom pour qu'on n'oublie
jamais les victimes de l'attentât à la
grande mosquée de québec ce soir le
témoignage des survivants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
moi j'ai quitté la maison à 7h30 j'étais
hésitant fait pour de faire la prière à
la maison d'aller à la mosquée parce que
je savais que la prière commence à 7h30
mais finalement je me suis dit ok je
vais aller à la mosquée
peut-être que je rattraperai une prière
je suis rentré à 19h30 puis là quand je
suis arrivé ici j'ai dû vous cache pas
que j'avais un sentiment de corps c'est
bizarre quand je suis arrivé un an
de fait personne rendue dans la salle de
prière une grande salle
là je voulais pas ouvrir toutes les
lumières là je veux juste la moitié de
la salle
[Musique]
j'entendais n'est pas derrière moi moi
j'étais comme j'ai dit mais je sais que
je suis toute seule
mais là j'entends des débats
puis je me suis tourné il y avait sa
capuche sur la tête
c'était
c'était notre fantôme
puis il a fait d'un veto
[Musique]
camadini j'entendais des bruits
j'entends des déballages réalisé que
quelqu'un je courais voir par la fenêtre
de ce qui se passe dehors je sais pas le
soin le bruit là d'où ça vient
bella je regardais bien varié là j'ai
compris tout de suite laissé le bruit
que j'ai entendu ces écoutes sont ils à
rentrer par la porte il ya deux portants
qui la rentrée par la porte non
se rend à la mosquée vers 19h55 à peu
près
ce moment là j'ai passé derrière le tube
limité de dow montait de 2 je voyais pas
ce renard d'acheter cachés ici en même
temps ne me cache pas complètement
alors j'ai pris une décision de me
diriger vers lomé arabe
et la première chose que j'ai pas en
fait j'ai pensé à mon fils tu dis en lui
il a sa mère donc une île correct
[Musique]
en ce moment là il a tiré deux coups de
feu au plafond
tout de suite j'ai réalisé que c'était
la même personne derrière laquelle j'ai
passé
puis j'ai réalisé que c'était un
attentat tout de suite mais l'effet
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de monde donc je
sais quand j'ai pas trouvé de place
taylor chien mais qui conclut je dis que
je suis comme ça j'ai pris tout de suite
mon téléphone et j'ai contacté une femme
tout
le policier lui même a paniqué dit ok
madame si vous ça sic à l'adresse moi je
connais même pas l'adresse non seulement
on a le réflexe que j'ai eu c'est de
rentrer de pouvoir faire quelque chose
de rentrer au lieu de sortir
il a visé il s'est concentré sur moi en
fait
je pensais je continue probablement
quatre ou trois bagues en ce moment là
là je suis tombé c'est là que j'ai reçu
une balle tu as été touché à calandre
ici
l'épaule gauche
il a j'attendais votre balle parce
qu'ils se trouvent y arriver il était ça
va arriver dans la tête
de plus en plus il sert plus
une balle derrière une autre image une
autre
ils mendient qu'il a chargés et puis
killer aux tournées qui l'attirait était
par terre et arrêté ray encore des coups
de feu directement proches
[Musique]
vous avez une personne qui me tenait en
arrière qui nous disait elle-même reste
avec nous et il me reste avec nous le
faire at il lieu
faire un pâté yeux mais moi je faisais
comme ça j'étais et je me suis réveillé
je faisais quand j'ai vu l'uniforme de
policier en ce moment là j'ai perdu
connaissance
je me suis quand même rassuré que
c'était la police mais j'ai perdu
connaissance mais c'était perte de
connaissance avant la mare en fait parce
que pour moi c'était pour moi c'était
fini
[Musique]
me glisse ici à marle le frère aymen qui
refuse à tout arrêter de voir les morts
par terre puis les hommes à compter de
pleurer
puis moi je cherchais que même je sais
comment ils font
[Musique]
je m'excuse
ils ont commencé à sortir les gens qui
étaient blessés
donc moi je te le deuxième qui a quitté
ligne je suis allée à l'hôpital où l'on
va me dit que vraiment je vous coûte
ville une grande transfusion sanguine
coûts d'opération
et j'étais en perte de connaissance de
moi de moi j'étais en coma artificiel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour la cnav
[Musique]
les positionne aloi sur place ont
constaté qu'il y avait plusieurs
victimes dont des gens qui sont décédés
on confirme l'idée si je ne confirmerai
pas le nombre de décès pour l'instant
j'ai 80 sont d ici là s'ils sont balayés
6 ans des enfants ici parce que j'étais
l'occident s'est unie pour vous belge a
pris ses qualités c'est que tu es comme
ça il y en a pas de sécurité qu'on se
sent plus en sécurité ici à québec la
ici à québec là on a une vision de 6 à
québec
une fusion des personnes mortes ici à
québec moi je travaillais
mon père était la boxe est ma soi que
l'auteur faisait papaye et là on n'est
pas capable de le rejoindre je pas son
téléphone
[Musique]
d'être en demies nuit un bouquin qu'on
est finalement arrivé à la cellule de
crise à partir de ce moment là que la
tante commencer la tente on attend on
attend
nathan
une des personnes qui étaient là mais
c'était un nouveau voisin puis un ami
très proche à mon père il ajouté une
voie puis il fond en larmes un peu puis
me prendre dans ses bras puis et midi
ils ont frappé devons pas nous ça
passait à ce moment lorsque j'ai
commencé à me doutais que mon père était
décédée si elle n'avait pas survécu
je sais pas de quelle façon c'est la
fuite et mas moment le défend chez nous
comment ça ce n'est le cd équipe de
journalistes qui appelait pour nous
demander no doubt m'en tape nos
réactions par rapport au décès n'ont pas
qu'on n'avait pas eu de confirmation de
court ce soir ça a été
ce que me rajouter ajouter l'insulté à
l'injure le camp tf on a fini par ce
n'était pas une bonne nouvelle et
je sais pas comment l'industrie d'autres
un tremblement de terre ou en fait non
indices pondérés sur souvent sur de toi
c'était juste tombé c'est
[Musique]
non
oh
et eux
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
selon le rapport médical j'ai reçu cette
balle j'ai une paralysie qui commence au
niveau 2 de la verte erin ces huit ans
que ce site capable de bouger les coûts
en maths est
ibra a
[Musique]
la vive le choix la décision de
débrancher en fait au début le médecin
ils lui ont dit que si j'allais survivre
j'allais perdre
j'allais survivre sans mémoire et ils
songent qu'à membres qui bouche puis je
vais pas moi même accepté de vivre lui
comme ça et que ce serait à faire donc
énorme pour elles elle tenait à ce que
est-ce que je sois maintenu en fait en
est à la max réanimation
j'ai des douleurs neuropathiques
constante c'est à cause surtout de la
balle que j'ai reçus au niveau de
membres et à cause de la taille d'une
ère donc il ya toujours cette douleur si
au niveau du cerveau en fait c'est une
nouvelle douleur qu'on appelle fronton
je te coupe
ouais c'est pas
je prends toujours les narcotiques les
douleurs c'est chaque lourd c'est tout
le temps
[Musique]
mais cinq jours oui bonjour merci passe
bien les pôles pôle travail travail
lorsque je me suis réveillé l'opération
là j'ai réalisé que le poids que mon
proche peut pas le bouger du trouble
[Musique]
je vous voyais démunies et vulnérables
si le premier temps où il vit le deal
est vidé desriac sens il la colère aussi
[Musique]
ça va pas
vous
[Musique]
les pires soit
j'étais encore fâché ça prend un peu de
temps aux du plus pur que je m'adapte
avec l'équpe alors dans votre quotidien
à la maison ou même au travail et pas
peur de l'utiliser aussi pour reprendre
cette assurance le lauquet problème
était perdu un petit peu en chemin cette
blessure l'autre la traîne avec toi
depuis maintenant presque un an
qu'est ce qu'elle représente pour toi ma
cicatrice
pour moi si mon tatouage même temps
alors je le vois je vois toutes les
martyrs qui ont retenti ce soir là je
vois aussi toute une blessée suit ceux
qui ont qui sait plusieurs balles je le
vois je vois chaque fois que je me dise
avis je le vois chaque fois que je
regarde un miroir et les là pour me
rappeler
je sais que je vais pas oublié et je
veux pas oublier je peux pas oublier
mais il est là pour me rappeler toujours
qui en drames qui s'y passe à québec il
faut jamais oublier ça
oh
[Musique]
on
c'est très difficile de se dire que ça
se fasse plus que ça arrive dans la cour
mais le 29 janvier dernier cet avis chez
nous je suis né à cherbourg jeu
d'origine algérienne très jeune à trou
aux morts quatre mois on est parti puis
en 94 il ya eu un attentat dans une
université
merci mon pas travailler il ya vu des de
ses collègues tombés aux mains d'un
tireur en étant 94 ans né en algérie ses
7500 kilomètres d'ici
puis mes parents sont dit non c'est pas
ça la vie qu'on veut offrir à nos
enfants fait que se sont expatriés 29
janvier 2017
mon père tombe aux mains d'un tireur à
québec à sainte foy c'est l'ironie de
ceux est tellement énorme que ça en est
quasiment ce que ça en est grotesque
on est partis exactement pour ça qu'on
est venu trouver ça ici ça m'a permis à
moi puis ça a permis à beaucoup de gens
de se rendre compte que ya clairement un
problème y aura clairement un trouble
identitaire profond c'est de lire en bas
d'un article qui parle des peines
possibles qui peuvent être courues par
accuser de lire d'après moi il n'a pas
fait assez
je n'aurais pas cru les soeurs
une tendance ici
ans
à seulement peux tu m'expliquer pourquoi
qu'a accepté de témoigner mais seulement
un visage couvert ce que je peux être
affichées parce que le fait d'être
affichées je trouve que ma peur
deviennent de plus en plus ça demande
plus en plus t'as peur des gens
maintenant
bah oui c'est plus comme avant c'est
plus comme avant avant je peux sortir là
dans la rue le loiret le soir le
maître-chien
je sors ça m'arrive de de dire je vais
prendre de l'air mettant le soir 10h02
soir jamais eu peur mais là c'est plus
comme avant c'est fini avant je pourrais
prénomme en salant les fenêtres lundi
conditionnelle qui sont ouverts pige en
fout même si les gens qui passent ils me
voient prier jamais pas là depuis je
m'assure de fermer la lumière ou de ne
pas prier devant un gros défi m
c'est plus comme avant
quelques mois avant le drame
malheureusement on a eu la visite d'un
groupe d'extrême droite sous forme de
visites d'intimidation pour
nous faire comprendre que nous n'étions
pas chez nous c'est aller jusqu'à
déposer une tête de porc dans une
mosquée c'est le muscat taguée avec des
croix gammées donc mosquée ça allait
jusqu'à
cassé des vitres c'est des signes qui
pourraient tromper personne que ça
allait arriver
beaucoup de gens qui m'ont dit après
c'est une scène que comme si j'avais
comme si je l'avais je l'avais imaginé
dans ta tête à chaque fois quelqu'un à
rentrer dans une mosquée avec la porte
derrière les gens il imaginait qu'il
allait y avoir quelqu'un qui allait
rentrer avec une kalachnikov avec
quelque chose enfin qui allait tirer sur
tout le monde et beaucoup de gens m'ont
dit ça et problème c'est que
personne n'a réagi jay a man who was
going to be blood un adepte à baradel
damas d'ananas la satellisation moi je
peux écrire sur tout mais dernièrement
j'ai créé sur l'événement - trop
reprises cécile et 24 mars 2010 est donc
pendant un prêt à céder tout essayé
voyage imminent yanhai dans la pac mac
tomates ou bill reilly
je parle un peu de ce qui s'est passé ce
soir là il veut ni quelqu'un qui
distribue la mort avec un grand avec 1,3
il a causé quelques dégâts
il a pensé qu ici balle va illuminer la
vie il a retourné rob rossi chemin en se
cachant de la peur et de la rente
on va y aller un autre poème le le mois
de juillet 2016 sans rire avant
l'attentât
de quoi je parlais rails tout jamais la
bastille habilement vasari bilal wal
mart je parlais de la bouteille et
beaucoup droit québec 10 fleurs ou si le
ciel qui bleu avec quelques nuages un
enfant tu vois c'est ici qu'on n'ait pas
la même d'un jeune garçon
comment ça s'est passé avec lui est ce
que comment on fait pour expliquer ça à
un enfant
je pense que c'est lui rentrer dedans tu
repars en test développé beaucoup de
phobie des peurs au point qu'il y ait
des fois qu'il m'arrive est effrayée ma
respiration si je respire encore mais
parfois elle se lève la nuit porte le
chercher si je suis encore nos examens
on les range à l'allongé sait pas on a
faim de titres à sept ans âge endroit ça
demande beaucoup d'efforts c'est pas
facile de jour au lendemain on est on
est confronté à avoir du tout le poids
du corps sur les bras sur des bras qui
sont déjà partants un très faible avec
des muscles affaibli par une
hospitalisation ont donné des coups de
poing samba l'enfant reprenne à tqs
apprend les kelleher suis pas une
tétraplégie reste une tétraplégie aussi
le monde change drastique de [ __ ] même
relations au niveau du couple la famille
du travail tu pars un peu tout les
points de repères il faut se
reconstruire fait c'est sûr que ces gens
l'ont un courage immense
enfin parce que cette norme alors
commence à l'est dans la taille de votre
chiberta votre super talent c'est beau
ça c'est excellent même si j'estime
gravement blessé j'aurais laon toute ma
vie si j'aurais pensé à me fouetter
c'est les autres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
wendy ward amène à dire à la parole aux
mines à 10,1
tourabi
la ville est partagée en trois parties
mon travail ma famille et ma mosquée je
suis imam bella dynaman autant pour le
voir
quatre quartiers où elle est à thème où
tous mus limon j'étais sur la limite
d'un point de rupture avec cette société
je ne pouvais pas concevoir que je
pouvais continuer à vivre dans un pays
où on commence à lever des armes les uns
contre les autres dans un monde gong
rennais par l'intolérance par la
violence par la montée des extrémismes
de tout bord ce que je constate
malheureusement c'est que il ya
plusieurs incidents qui ont été
rapportées qui sont extrêmement
alarmants qui était à l'époque alarmant
qui ont abouti malheureusement
à ce drame de janvier 2017 bien qu'il
soit très difficile de faire le lien de
cause à effet mais toujours est il il
faut que tout le monde il faut que tout
le monde fasse son propre examen de
conscience dans ce pays
ce soir au téléjournal une mosquée du
saguenay aspergé de sang de porc un
premier dérapage dans le débat sur la
charte des valeurs québécoises
le débat autour de la religion la
laïcité ou les accommodements
raisonnables viennent avant l'attentât
du 29 janvier
les événements à caractère islamophobe
ont commencé à défrayer la manchette dès
2013 en plein coeur d'un débat sur la
laïcité
les tensions sont palpables dans
plusieurs villes du québec
la profanation de la mosquée de saguenay
il ya deux semaines cette jeune femme
qui aurait été congédié pour avoir porté
le voile
et puis maintenant une famille musulmane
qui se serait fait injurier et craché au
visage en place entre commercial à
québec la charte des valeurs n'est
jamais adopté mais les tensions elles
persistent l'immigration devient un
sujet particulièrement sensible
[Musique]
c'est dans ce contexte qu'un groupe
identitaire voit le jour
la meute dans les mois qui vont suivre
la meute et d'autres groupes semblables
seront de plus en plus actif pour
défendre leur point de vue sur
l'immigration
[Applaudissements]
à l'été 2016 le centre culturel
islamique de québec et cibler
directement par des gestes dont les
auteurs restent inconnues l'un des
fidèles a eu toute une surprise en
découvrant une tête de porc dans un
emballage cadeau devant les portes du
centre culturel
puis vient le 29 janvier 2010 cette
semaine violence jusque là impensable
on a certainement ce média qui ont
amplifié la haine depuis l'apparition de
la charte
l'agression à cette communauté et une
escalade permanente
c'est à ce moment qu'un vieux débats
reviennent à l'ordre du jour à québec il
n'existe aucun cimetière où enterrer les
citoyens musulmans dans la capitale et
les musulmans de la région de québec ont
finalement leur cimetière ils ont voté
en faveur de l'achat d'un terrain à
saint-apollinaire sur la réussite mais
la controverse éclate
des résidents de la petite municipalité
s'oppose au projet qui finit par être
rejeté lors d'un référendum
un autre coup dur pour les musulmans
tout le monde nous a offert son aide son
soutien et cetera d'hydra mais quand on
arrive aux réalités
on va pas les reins on voit pas les
mêmes effets j'ai dit vous faire ça on a
eu 9 à vous faire
peu de temps après la ville de québec
annonce la vente d'un terrain pour y
implanter un cimetière musulman
sas avons de la difficulté à retenir mes
émotions quand vous avez fait d'annoncé
officielle mais la bonne nouvelle sera
vite assombri par un autre drame
un incendie criminel peut être gestes
haineux donc les enquêteurs le dire on a
réduit en cendres la voiture de mohamed
labidi de toute cette spirale de
xénophobie personne est vraiment
ressorti indemne
c'est un échec collectif c'est un
un échec que tout le monde tout le monde
mais absolument tout le monde dans notre
société québécoise doit assumer
c'est au moment où les pensées croule où
les choses vont mal où on n'a plus
besoin de gens qui vont continuer à être
ce trait d'union entre entre les
communautés
[Musique]
bon
oh oh oh
on
bon ça me fait du bien
c'est un fait de bien après les efforts
de la semaine au centre d'adaptation
donc je me repose
c'est un repos psychologique moi ça me
fait du bien d'être avec les enfants
j'ai trois enfants et yum il a 9 ans mon
fils youssouf la cinq ans ma petite
fille à la 22 mois s'appelle maria son
fils youssouf hadji diagnostiqué autiste
1° sévère et a besoin tout le temps de
surveillance je peux pas bouger je peux
pas me décorer de ma chaise pour je dois
toujours tout le temps appelé ma femme
quand il est juste à côté de moi je peux
pas l'empêcher de faire une gaffe c'est
difficile mais c'est la [ __ ] et yogan
beaucoup joué au soccer
la personne qui l appelle de plus
pouvoir jouer avec lui simplement parce
que lui ne veut pas accepter ça moi je
lui dis c'est toujours ayoub on garde
espoir dans la vie si on a peur et
quelque chose et on a d'autres choses un
peu un peu gagné d'autres joueurs
opèrent des choses ne peut gagner moi
j'ai perdu ma condition physique mais
j'ai gagné la solidarité j'y gagne
l'entr'aide j'ai gagné beaucoup 2 de lie
avec mes amis
[Musique]
je suis très posé judiciaire ça fait dix
ans que je fais ce métier ça va remonter
après l'acte et moi ce que je suis rien
dit des choses que je n'hésite pas à
avancer mais comment les gens témoigne
laure amour leur sport voilà ivoire il
vient au casier pour changer pour
mettront une forme de travail
j'ai trouvé un coeur sur mon casier la
couleur bleue donc ça peut signifier la
ville pour signifier le cgm ce qui
signifie le plein de choses donc ça va
ça fait ma journée
elle est encore
un nivellement tragique comme ça avec
tout ravages qu'il a fait avec ce que
les victimes qu'il a fait des gens qui
veut y aller chercher le positif le
temps est un des points positifs du
sentiment c'est que les gens s'en
rendent compte qu il ya des musulmans
ici il faudra y aller les voir on m'a
bien au chaud je porte votre collation
porter un lait legault de fromage c'est
mon rayon avec le sourire qui a des
souris tout souriait il com - mais 15 du
synthé ville c'était épouvantable sustt
affreux et puis là-bas quand j'ai vu ça
j'ai dit j'ai prié pour lui que ça irait
mieux
puis dès aujourd'hui si vous savez
évidemment que ça y est des musulmans
ont mis et un autre un autre jésus outre
à main que nous ont ils pris mes autres
maps que - madame lapierre et dit
qu'elle a beaucoup pris pour toi et prix
paul mon dieu que toi mais je pense que
c'est le même
je pense qu'ils prient le même vieux
c'est ça
donc j'ai pris hier c'est souvent la
même adresse
[Musique]
selon un compte
c'est comme si je suis né ici une
deuxième et une deuxième chance
c'est des images qui me reviennent
presque partout encore une fois ici
c'est encore centre est présente mais
c'est pas juste le négatif qui sort il
ya aussi le positif plus fort
je pense que le virement m'a pas changé
mais c'est comme une alerte
une alarme pour dire la démission à
faire tes devoirs à faire et des choses
à corriger
donc c'est le moment
[Musique]
j'ai pas envie parce que je suis
algérien d'origine que tout mais mes
aspirations soient et coupet 8 mai les
enfants vont porter le nom de mon père
j'ai pas envie que parce que leur nom
c'est belkacemi la vie soit plus est
mon père est pauvre lui que je
m'apitoyais sur sept personnes occupées
jeu se plaignent qu'ils cherchent la
pitié piles et les accolades et non
c'est arrivé puis tout faire en sorte
que mon père soit pas décidée en vain et
c'est pour ça fou j'avais parlé dans les
écoles à des jeunes femmes à ce qu'ils
puissent avoir quelqu'un à qui parler
dolphin
souvent que si sa gueule me connaissait
sont ces rencontres et c'est sans arrêt
puisse parler se serait jamais arrivé ce
que j'aime est arrivé je sors un certain
médecin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la première fois que je suis retourné le
voir jouer au soccer en fait c'était un
samedi puis moi c'était vraiment très
long pour moi c'était une surprise pour
lui était content puis je voyais parlé
avec le coach je ne montrais pas pas
aider la pop à l hiver et des cordons
aussi un mois j'étais très content de le
voir jouer
c'est un réconfort pour moi ça fait du
bien sûr
petit à petit j'ai c'est de nous
retourner à ma vie à mon rôle de père
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
audigier savais même pas comment mesurer
le bâton
sybase de la gagner
un boys comme les autres ça il permet
aussi je pense de dire ben c'est pas
tout le monde qui veulent pas intégrer
des gens qui viennent d'ailleurs
puis c'est la preuve et russie
je comprends le ton bateau au jeu
surtout comment ça a été a connu qui a
fui comme un héros me dire un grand
joueur de rock'n'roll
ils m'ont expliqué ça ça veut dire
rester là et ça m'a touché beaucoup de
monde
moi je trouve à jouer on rentre c'est
comme s'intégrer à la société
[Musique]
je m'engage à condamner toutes remarques
racistes islamophobes aussi banal
puisse-t-elle semblait je m'engage à ne
pas rester silencieuse devant tout
propos et c'est signé une québécoise
tout comme tours je m'engage à être plus
alertes envers toute forme de
discrimination je n'ai pas envie d'être
témoin de gestes aussi horrible c'est le
mouvement l'etrat toi ou un organisme
non invité la population de québec et de
la province de québec en général a
envoyé des lettres à la communauté ce
mamie aux personnes qui ont été touchées
de près dans ces d'être lorsque je
voyais dans celle que j'ai lu il y avait
un thème qui revient qui revenait
souvent le fait qu'on se connaissait pas
et qu'on pouvait être amis finalement
foudre est apprendre à se connaître
quelque chose qui est arrivé c'est grave
ce qui est arrivé qu'un gros grosfillex
et s'est cassé s'est déchiré puis sabin
foule faut le reconnaître il faut que
les jambes qu'avec le reconnaissent
puis il faut que ensemble décidons
décide ensuite de leurs tipis de d'aller
de l'avant
ça va pas se faire tout seul puis ça va
certainement pas se faire c'est peu dire
que les résolutions au niveau politique
on changer quoi que ce soit à ce niveau
là c'est les gens c'est notre devoir à
nous c'est à nous de faire en sorte que
justement que ce pont le se construit
explique s'entretiennent surtout
[Musique]
le 29 janvier 2017 c'est aussi
l'histoire de ceux qui ne sont pas
restés les bras croisés devant l'horreur
dès le lendemain du drame des milliers
de personnes marchent dans les rues
autour de la grande mosquée pour dire
non à la haine
[Musique]
quelques jours plus tard l'église
catholique décide de célébrer une messe
en hommage à ceux qui ont péri
une semaine après l'attentât 700
citoyenne québec marche à nouveau tous
ensemble en signe de solidarité avec les
victimes
à la fin février on tient un grand
spectacle pour célébrer la diversité
culturelle
[Musique]
l'église anglicane de québec met aussi
la main à la pâte
à l'automne le doyen invite les
musulmans dans sa cathédrale
juste pour apprendre à se connaître le
temps d'une soirée
les plus belles initiatives ne
ramèneront jamais les dix fauché le 29
janvier 2017
mais elles sont le reflet d'une prise de
conscience qui s'est fait après cette
prière où tout a basculé
[Musique]
le lendemain des attentats las de voir
du monde qui bouge est pour nous ça m'a
touché vraiment il ya des gens qui nous
regardent à travers nier les gens qui
sont racistes mais on ne savait pas
qu'il ya d'autres là qui tiennent à nous
puis là ce jour là justement il nous a
il le peuple ici là le le québec nous a
montré que où il ya des gens qui
viennent à nous je continue à rêver que
je vais avoir un québec dans quelques
décennies à québec apaiser un québec
prospère un québec où tout le monde peut
vivre c'est sûr que j'étais blessé ici
mais en même temps j'étais sauvée par du
monde ici ça renforce le lien que j'ai
on vers la ville de québec à la vie
reprend pied
c'est ça j'essaierai de trouver notre
activité notre de notre d'autres choses
que je pourrais faire avec ma condition
moi ce que je souhaite c'est que le 29
janvier 2010 est restée gravée la
mémoire collective québécoise puis qu'on
se souvienne puis qu'on se dise plus
jamais jamais je n'ai je sais pas ce que
ça prend toujours un drap pour qui les
gens se rencontrent quelque chose à
[Musique]
ça va prendre du temps mais c'est pas
amener quelque chose de meilleur
oh
[Musique]
vous êtes probablement aussi ému que
nous alors on prend une petite pause et
tout de suite après on en discute avec
l'équipe qui a produit ce reportage
restez avec nous on est de retour
enquête avec la réalisatrice catherine
leblanc le journaliste alexandre duval
pour faire ce reportage là vous avez dû
entrer dans la vie des gens qui avaient
été vraiment durement touchée par
l'attentât la grande mosquée et sa peau
du est facile d'obtenir les témoignages
c'est sûr que de convaincre des gens qui
vivent avec les séquelles de cet
attentat de témoigner à la caméra de se
montrer dans toutes leurs vulnérabilités
sa peau était une mince tâche
et je vous le cacherai pas d'essuyer des
refus entre autres avec les femmes des
défunts mais un premier anniversaire
d'un événement dramatique comme ça ça
tend à réactiver les traumatismes chez
les victimes alors il faut un peu savoir
se mettre à leur place et les gens
avaient peur de témoigner avait toujours
la crainte d'être victimes de gestes
seins nus commis envers eux aussi leurs
visages étaient reconnus faut dire aussi
que la communauté musulmane de québec
ceux qui fréquentent la grande mosquée
de québec et c'est très serré donc il
fallut souvent convaincre plusieurs
personnes pour atteindre une seule
personne qu'on a rencontrés dans notre
reportage
et merci d'avoir recueilli ces
témoignages qui est absolument
exceptionnelle merci à ceux qui ont
accepté de se confier
on espère que vous avez apprécié
l'émission de cette semaine une émission
assez spéciale et on vous donne rendez
vous la semaine prochaine pour une autre
enquête
[Musique]